now we've got professor vilem Schafer
another German vice president of
research at the University of paderborn
and executive director of the rail cap
project rail cabs that's what we want to
hear about I don't know if you've ever
taken trains in this country but I think
British people would be delighted to
have good train transport on demand that
worked on schedule and you know didn't
break down all the time and was
affordable and all that anyways tell us
about them what is it hard airport mover
driverless taxi service type trains that
we can see across countries yeah
actually that's a very well placed
comment even the german railway system
is deteriorating and i don't see that
much difference between england and
germany and i have taken english streams
and you strained the number of times so
let me talk about what we have in mind
and of reading i should just make a
disclaimer think compared with the other
project we are still very much at
research stage but so i think we have
something to offer first thing is that
this rail cap company we created about
five years ago it's so far basically a
company which has been created by the by
the Prince of investigators of the
project namely by my colleagues and
myself to offer some possibilities for
investment and the difference too many
other projects is that we have a truly
interdisciplinary team namely from
mechanical engineering electrical
engineering software engineering which
I'm a part of and that's very different
from any other of this engineering
project in germany and i think around
the world and you will see in a second i
think why that is important second thing
is about the vision of the project what
we really target is different from what
you know from let's say these
traditional people movers and actually
there is a not very nice system at
heathrow recently installed and we
talked to the people who built the
system at Heathrow and they visited as
we visited them so I'm very well aware
of what's going on but what we target is
really long distance travel
and long distant traveling of course
then neatly comes together with short
distance traveling but the key thing is
really to take the advantages already
existing in basically available traffic
despite the problems we just mentioned
which is really to some extent energy
efficiency many people in one car and a
lot less energy wasted then when you
drive with your own car standing a
traffic jam for a long time in addition
the cars are very heavy by far too heavy
for what you want to achieve they are
basically heavy because you want to be
safe in terms of crashes or in cases of
crashes so all these waste-to-energy
right still people like to use cars for
obvious reasons very comfortable easy to
get too easy to get in take all your
luggage in whatever you can think of
right so how can we combine those things
and first of all I give you an idea of
how the scenario looks like small caps
that's where the name comes from which
run on demand rather than on schedule
they are available 24 hours 7 days they
run driverless you don't need a driver
who is operating them and you can change
them easily between cargo and passenger
rail caps and you can have different
versions of these cars you see on the
right side for passenger comfort traffic
or less comfort traffic like this
picture reminds you probably the London
tube and then you see in the middle the
key thing is those cars come form
convoys on long distances and that saves
energy because the windshield factor is
taken into account that's one key thing
they run touchless so they can split off
and can run to the destination you want
to go right and as I said you get them
on demand rather than on a schedule
final thing is you can reuse existing
track so that's really an existing track
system with a difference that you have a
linear engine in the middle put in in
the middle so it's basically a magnetic
train but not elevated and that brings
me to the technology here we are that
gives an idea of the key technological
parts and I don't want to go about all
of them but one key thing is this
so-called track guidance model module
which are two different different
independent axles which can be steered
independently and that really makes up
for this loss of energy compared with
the magnetically elevated trains they
run friction free
I'm very fast that was one of the
reasons why they were invented and this
friction freeness can now basically but
she's not complete but almost by smart
mechatronics as we call it so basically
what we do is we have wheels equipped
with sensors and those sensors measure
the distance of the tracks and then they
are a curative steered in such a way
that they don't have any friction
anymore with the tracks on the side so
only on the ground right and that is a
key thing for achieving energy
efficiency and of course also helping to
wear to avoid aware of the physical
component two key things which also come
with magnetically elevated trains but of
course for magnetic elevated trains you
have to build all new tracks and you
cannot reuse things and a lot of other
problems so this is more than a dream
and just on paper and now I go back and
now we could show the video so this is
our test track which runs on campus or
with which exists on campus and you can
see 22 small cars now in the scale of 1
to 2.5 you can still not right on them
or you're very brave second thing is so
I have to yeah this is the test track
from an aerial view gives you an idea
with the stator in between and there is
the car how it looks as a technology car
and here's just an idea of how big the
track is and how scarred as fast the
cars are currently so basically we run
up to almost 40 km/h currently so final
thing is there is a simulator build
scale of one to one so you can now walk
in it and you can get the feeling of
being run in it I had a video as well
for that but that doesn't work virtually
so that people also get an experience of
what it means sitting in a car without a
driver and then being merged into a
convoy right with a speed which sort of
looks like you need a driver but of
course what I'm always telling is when
you run when you fly you also think the
pilot is in control but in most cases
the software is in control right it's
just physiologically different in the
sense that you can see directly whereas
in planes of course there's some
distance between you and the cockpit
final slide some calculations about
comparison with existing systems with a
convoy of four trains of
cars you are actually as efficient as a
fully occupied IC or France repeat and
as you can get usually the cars or the
convoys are longer than four cars when
you travel long distance there are a lot
more cars which basically take the same
direction and of course usually I SI es
especially are not fully okay fully
occupied so basically the the graph
opens up like a scissor and actually in
our favor right we can we wrap it up
brilliant and now in the interest of
saving time thank you very much
I'm just gonna ask a very quick question
if you had all the money you need it how
many years to make this operative in
Germany maximum 10 years better than
general generation for our nuclear
reactor um some other questions unless
there are none the floor is yours there
Greg offer from Imperial College again
my I have an interest in this kind of
technology my main question is around
embedded infrastructure and alternatives
so the main criticism I would have is
that this relies on embedded
infrastructure granted some may already
exist but to roll this out on a large
scale you'd have to invest in a lot of
infrastructure there are credible
alternatives like platooning of existing
vehicles which are retrofit able and
give you okay maybe not all the benefits
but close so how would you compare to
what large number of automotive
companies are developing in terms of
platooning technology hmm yeah
platooning is obviously somewhat close
but first of all 4 platoon you also have
to invest in infrastructure they don't
run on normal roads right that's
basically i would say basically
impossible because there's so much
disturbance by the environment that you
can hardly control cars on highways in
platooning without doing extra things
like what they talk about is take the
middle lane and make that special for
platooning things like that that's
that's number one number two is of
course platooning doesn't really come
with the efficiency of this engine right
and we talk about energy Jane
game-changer tonight right and I think
that's the key thing which maybe not so
clear but the key thing is really to
take that magnetic engine and use it
efficiently in such a way that you reuse
infrastructure you have the power with
the tracks I mean they're in cables
above but it's much easier to put them
down rather than to build all this new
new type of things right so that makes
it competitive which doesn't mean
actually that platooning should no be
followed on fully aware of the situation
that actually some German car
manufacturers work heavily on platooning
actually were involved even in one of
these projects so it's very familiar for
me I think those are two things which
come together or should
to go one last very quick question right
here Tony cousin price from open
democracy one of the problems we have in
UK and a lot of place a lot of
industrialized countries is capacity on
the rail system does your system
irrespective of the technology does it
increase capacity on a given amount of
track I mean at least you are flexible
in terms of you can increase Kappas
capacity easily by basically putting on
new caps on the track right so you can
really adjust your your amount of cars
you run to the capacity you need which
means that you don't need like in trains
you basically have to estimate
anticipate what what what will come
right and then Friday trains friday
afternoon trends in Germany are much
longer than let's say wednesday
afternoon trains right and in some cases
it works in some cases doesn't work and
of course with these small cars you're a
lot more flexible all right then yeah
and it might make it easier to sort of
provide services yeah small it's
definitely easier because you can easily
get them from some let's say some garage
with some some storage place and and and
put them and put them on track thank you
very much for this probably most side
pie proposal
you